when i was a kid
guys like me were brought up to follow
coach
hey jerkle
what'd you say what
first let me say congratulations on the
film and alessandra i'll start with you
because your character really sort of in
this film i would say takes the tony
mantle a bit so
talk about when you first found out from
david that you were going to be taken on
this role and uh sort of continuing this
really i would say epic series that so
many people loved was it daunting
yeah i mean i obviously i felt
well i look i felt just
so happy that at this
late stage of my career that i'd been
given the the chance to uh you know
have a big lead role in a movie like
this and i i had never really had that
opportunity before so i was
uh you know i was just so happy that
that uh it had come along and
that david was allowed to cast who he
wanted and that he
he wanted me to do it and i um
i was aware of the legacy of the show
and how important uh tony and
this guy's dad had been for so many
people and so
yeah there was a there was a feeling
like those were big shoes to fill but on
the other hand
david had
i was so clever to have designed this
uh new story around a character that
never really existed in the show except
in a kind of mythological way that it
really
gave me a sense of freedom that i could
invent a character
from scratch and and that it was such a
different kind of character such a
different kind of focal point to the
story than
um tony soprano had been in the series
um
so
you know it was it was both things at
once the feeling of excitement and the
pressure
and also um you know just a feeling that
i had a kind of
blank sheet of paper that i could write
on and and uh and
and you know come up with you know in my
imagination
of a complete person
that's awesome uh michael i again with
your character playing a younger version
of your father that just adds an
entirely
dynamic so i would imagine those first
conversations with david and also with
alan like how did that go because it's
just i can only imagine what it was like
both exciting but also emotional
yeah um
yeah it was all the emotions kind of
like you just said you know i had
auditioned over a period of sort of like
like two three months so i didn't have
like a moment of like you got the job do
you want to do it it was kind of like a
slow burn of like
auditioning and getting closer to the
character and not
it was all on the page so
i sort of understood
um
this is gonna be a different tony this
is something i can
add to
this character that maybe hasn't been
completely exp explored
in this way his sensitivity and
nerdiness and
um
sort of
it surprised me when i when i read the
version of this tony and i think when
you read something and you're surprised
that's really exciting
so i was really excited to do it and and
and nervous but i i think that
the beginning conversations were nothing
but
great because
david's writing we all understood this
character
what his sort of emotional arc was what
his relationship was because it's so
clear on the page you know
i love that um and leslie your character
first of all i loved um what you were
able to do with this character it's
really incredible because in the history
of gangster movies let's be honest black
folks really don't get the best
the best way of it uh but i felt herald
and so sort of showing a depth to that
character is really interesting and i
just wondered what your conversations
were with david or with alan about
honoring that point in time but also you
know being true to a complexity within
the character
yeah
uh well um a lot like michael just said
that you know when you
work on a david chase
uh project you know it's you're in the
hands of real auteur you know i mean
that's he he really
gives you so much on the page to uh to
pull from and then i just tried to um i
thought about my grandfather a lot
who you know who
migrated like
so many like six million black people
from the south to the north uh between
1910 and 1970 and
my grandfather of course got to new york
city and
[Music]
like somebody worked in a factory you
know he worked in a factory for a few
decades retired from that factory uh
harold takes a different path once he
gets to the north but the
the impetus was the same so i i
understood that you know i understood
that part of harold because i knew my
granddad for so long so when i look on
screen that's that's kind of what i see
an homage to
um
to
the the reality of an experience that i
you know that i was so close to as a kid
i love that um and also this is a bit of
a fun one because i only have a couple
minutes left but everybody gets like a
fun
mob name for these movies like you know
big [ __ ] and folly and so yeah i'm
gonna ask y'all what would your mom name
be if you could have one either based on
yourself and michael because i'm gonna
hope that you've thought about it longer
i'm gonna start with you oh god a mom's
name
um
um i would say that i was like gossip
something like oh that's good in the
mouth
[Laughter]
chris jackson gave me one chris jackson
gave me one before before i left
hamilton
he used to call me silky
alessandro michael y'all got anything
come on you lay down i guess i i'd be
scaredy cat you're scared
[Music]
hey listen
like the fright or whatever i'll let's
not enjoy the frightening
right right i know but but i feel like
yeah that's a good one too because like
the the opposite would be true
he's like the most dangerous
of the crew yeah yeah
all right we're going to call you
michael on the quiet like like
all right
who everyone calls them hollywood smooth
the [ __ ] i think is so funny
they call stanford hollywood smooth so
i'll steal his
what do you want richard i'll be honest
with you
i want to do a good deed leo i'll start
with you um you've been in one of the
most iconic if not the most iconic mob
movies ever so i just have to ask i
gotta go i missed it oh i was saying
you've been in one of if oh my god i got
it
okay uh mom movies ever so like is what
did alan and david have to tell you to
be like okay one more because like
that's like you reached everest but you
don't need to go back well it's not a
matter of needing to go back or it's
just
it's fun to play pretend and it's really
fun to play pretend that with people who
are very
passionate about doing it and david
chase is as intense as it gets about
wanting to put
the story that he wants
uh
in front of people
that's so great and then michaela for
you i'm just curious because you've done
obviously this is your first big english
language thing but does the sopranos is
that something that like made it across
um over there was it as big over there
as it was over here or did you have to
get like studied up like from the jump
when you got cast the second one
dancer
that's easy well so what was it like um
sort of going through the series did you
go back and watch a bunch or how did you
sort of study
it i watched the whole thing in in a
month when i got the role and i felt in
love i mean
that's so great and then when you were
first talking with david with your
character because obviously your
character is
a new person within this story although
they're part of the universe what was
his conversations because not only is
she intricate to sort of show um the
aspect of women at this time in this
part of that universe but also the
immigrant side of that as well like so
what were your conversations with uh
david on that we talked about a lot of
things
starting with the dialect because i
speak neapolitan and i but i'm come from
rome so i've learned
the dialect
then we spoke about you know the way i
move the way she moves the way
she could she could have been different
than the others as a real italian one as
a native
so it's been it's been a challenge we
we created her together on set last
question for both of you what would be
your mob nickname because um we've been
asking everyone mine is because i like
to gossip a little bit my name's
jacqueline jackie the mouth
but
jackie the mouth yeah cause i'm a little
bit of a gossip with my friends
because you don't get to pick your name
so it's going to be what people think of
you so that's it what about you ray real
quick and you mikayla and then i gotta
get oh no
nice
nice i'm with that
kayla i could be the lady
let me go talk to him he only listens to
dickie both of you had like such a
daunting past because you had the
characters that were in the series the
whole time and you had to like
still be honor that but then bring your
own character to it so uh billy i'll
start with you what was it like sort of
bringing this other side
polly out there and then like how much
did you rely on the series to sort of
tell you how you wanted to do it oh i i
all relied on this series to tell you
the truth
those were the foundation building
blocks of the character i
had the opportunity again an awesome
opportunity to play polly walnuts um
it was just hours of sitting and
digesting everything that tony did with
the character and just kind of playing
in that world in the mental head space
watching mannerisms through the guy
the
cadence of the way he talks the way he
moves you know just hours and hours of
doing it to then throw it
off the window you know
yeah that's like the whole point to not
think about it that's good and then
corey was yours too um this is junior
but i would even say like this is a
different side of him we sort of see
why he becomes the crotchety old man
that we see at the beginning of the
series and so did you have a little bit
more i would say latitude to play with
that to sort of see his shifts
throughout the course of this film
yeah yeah i mean
i think they did such a great job
writing this early you know part of his
life and to give him a sense of
of those motivations and those
those resentments that by the time we
see him
in the series
uh those resentments seem to sort of
basically you know
comprise his entire personality um
uh
you know it was
uh it was very it was very i think
smartly
smartly done
to sort of show
these
two uncle figures in in in tony's life
uh his real uncle
who gets no respect and then this
this adoptive uncle who's the cool guy
boy you're so good in the movie
you're you you are i love you
y'all are great i i will have to say the
other thing about this one too just with
the way that your characters are is the
interactions that you have with the
other versions like you know cory when
you're talking to michael as tony but
really i want to talk about you and vera
because the
olivia jr thing was such a big part of
the series and then to see
just how they are in this one and how
much fun you guys had with that because
i it took me a good two minutes to be
like is that really here underneath all
that because it was
yeah i remember when we did the first
table read
and
just like hearing that voice coming out
of vera she just
nailed it um
it was really really incredible
um
yeah i mean those those two characters
are
so
tricky it is such a you know it's such a
i think that's why the series was so
compelling and good
was
these characters are it's such a
dysfunctional family you know they're
literally trying to kill each other and
the the level of aggression aggression
and passive aggression in every
direction is just it's so dysfunctional
and yet
they're so
vibrant and funny
and unique you know these characters
they bounce off each other huh love and
respect it's still even there yeah yeah
that was the biggest table read i think
i've ever been at actually
really it was massive
there was over 50 people there was it
not it was an event it was a real event
it was an event i remember that now yeah
and that's so great to just see this
cast because you know from all the new
characters that are brought on to also
the folks that are carrying over from
the series i feel like all of them get
their moment to shine and there's all
those little touches from the series the
callbacks and the sort of easter eggs
but billy i want to ask you because i
even like saw like just from his hair to
like him doing his nails at the table
but i was curious if alan or david talk
to you about any of the other paulie uh
easter eggs that they wanted to put in
this one to make sure you knew about
like hey by the way we're doing this for
this reason
uh no they do not let me in on it i just
haven't seen it as much as
my journey through this film was like uh
david
is it okay can i do that is that cool
can i
you know it's like yeah
um
i don't know again like
paulie's journey through this film is
you know on the the peripheral and stuff
like that and just supporting and like
building blocks of it i i honestly had
fun with it and just
you know showed up every day with what i
thought was the energy of
what paulie brings to to the scenes um
yeah no david uh again was the guy that
was the north star through this whole
process and i just kind of turned to him
for advice and ideas and
you know am i on the path that you feel
good with yeah love it so i've been
asking everyone this one and i'll give
you mine so you don't feel embarrassed
that i've been asking everyone what
their mob nickname would be i'm a bit of
a guy personally like personally yeah so
like mine i said so my name is
jacqueline and i hate being called
jackie but you don't get to pick your
nickname so i would say jackie the mouse
because i'm a little bit of a gossip
according to my friends
i know you don't get to pick your
nickname so that's what my friends would
probably go with me but uh billy what
would yours be it's
billy the kid obviously is like number
one or billy the jackhammer
uh how about cue ball
cue ball for the keyboard okay
all right i i'll let you go with that
one but you could have been like corey
the suave and i don't think any of the
ladies would have been mad about that
but all right well exactly you can't
come up with your own nickname so it's
true
i want to do whatever i can to help the
family
you've been a part of literally some of
the biggest shows on television and
really even at the forefront of what we
call like peak tv
but what is it about the sopranos
because i feel like this show is just
different even from like the west wing
you did deadwood um game of thrones
obviously but this show in particular i
find it was like the number one show in
the pandemic hit everybody was watching
it again yeah it wasn't funny i mean
that was we heard about that that uh
people were going back to it when they
had time um i don't know my tv career
was funny because i i came out of film
school you know not interested in tv i
think looking down on tv and thinking i
want to be a movie maker like my heroes
um
and i didn't know that i was going to
sort of stumble backwards into a kind of
golden age of tv uh because doing
sopranos and then mad men and some of
the other ones um
were wonderful experiences to have
mostly because i was saying no to all
the stuff i thought was boring and so
the things that were really exciting
like when i first
they sent me the pilot for the sopranos
and i thought wow what is this it feels
more cinematic than you know the most
movies i'm seeing and it expects you to
be a little bit more intelligent when
you're watching it but it pays you off
in in sort of genre ways too so i was
surprised i think to see that it hasn't
aged for people that there's a younger
generation that's here seeing it for the
first time
and i think it you know it comes down to
david's voice and finding you know using
the gangster story to ask all the big
questions um and because he's david
chase not giving you any answers so that
you know famously the series ended with
a kind of cliffhanger um uh for some
people the russian guy that wandered off
in the woods he never came back i mean
it's it's very much the david chase um
uh approach to sort of
make you engage you make you lean
forward ask the big questions and then
not finish it for you not not not wrap
it up and i think that's one reason why
there's a
an ongoing fascination with the show
i love that um also i guess you
mentioned it but david approaching you
to do this because first of all just the
idea that they wanted to do a movie is
kind of interesting especially the time
frame they wanted to do it on um how did
he approach you and what were those
first conversations like it was all very
uh
succinct because i hadn't heard he was
doing anything until he called and said
there was a script and did i want to
read it
yeah um
obviously
and when i heard it was a prequel that
made perfect sense because there's i
can't imagine there ever being a sequel
to the show because david would have to
explain what happened in holstein's
diner and he doesn't want to explain
that um
and
so
reading it realizing it was going to be
the same tone uh it just became clear
that this was a great chance um
there aren't that many movies being made
by studios that are character driven
like this or psychologically
curious like this or as dark as this um
and it's because of the love for the
show that we were able to you know sneak
this one in
i also have to say too like i've watched
the sopranos probably about six or seven
times all the way through and revisited
episodes i don't know how many times of
my favorite but and even i was having
trouble keeping up with all of the
little easter eggs or the big project
that i don't want to do so is that like
off to the side on like a script no like
hey
reference to this this is a reference to
that or did you just have to trust
in that this was part of it i think um
the you know i've been on productions
where the easter eggs are very
consciously deployed and and uh and sort
of fan service i think this one was more
um
i think david wanted to bring a director
in who knew the show and had the show in
him sort of already so that's one reason
why it made sense to bring me in so we
didn't have to think oh this is that
time you know this is that that episode
where it's just it's sort of just part
of the same world we're in so these
things are float up um and
there's a couple of almost catch phrases
in the movie that i know fans will you
know
love being listened to be waiting for um
but uh besides some of the more glaring
ones like that no i think it was just
being true to the world and
um a chance to echo those things you
know naturally sort of i mean like even
the baby gets in on it y'all were like
deep on this man that was that was a big
deal yeah because i you know i i
i finished that baby storyline on the
show uh as a director so to begin it was
pretty um
powerful yeah um again i don't want to
give too much away but last thing i'll
ask you this maybe you don't have this
one so i'm going to give you two options
but i've been asking everyone what their
mob name would be but as you as the
director as you're behind the scenes i
will also give you your favorite moment
from the series since that's more behind
the camera type of thing so either one
you can answer either mob name or
favorite moment okay you know if i had
like i need 24 hours to think about the
vape the best mob name i keep changing
my mind and i've never that also it
would have to be pretty uh i know one
thing it could be
it's the least mob name in the world and
that's why this would suit me uh
jim gandolfini is one of the few people
ever gave me a nickname
uh i don't know why he got me that
nickname but he did and it's the most
ridiculous nickname in the world and i
think it's like you know calling [ __ ]
[ __ ] it just it happens and that's who
you are uh
jim gandolfini used to call me cupcake
so i guess
i guess that's my mob name
as far as your nephew goes
i'm listening
stay out of his life
[Music]
yourself